we're still looking for a way of dealing
with non-additive matrices
so in this section let's try and develop
a heuristic
in practice researchers often assume
that every internal node of a phylogeny
corresponds to a speciation event
which is defined as an event where one
species divides
into two in this case
we need to place limits on the internal
nodes of the tree
for example if we're working with
unrooted trees
our requirement is that every internal
node needs to have degree 3.
this means that regardless of where the
root is when we progress from the root
to a leaf
every time we encounter an internal node
the tree splits into two pieces
for example if we place the root on the
limb of the squirrel monkey here
then as we progress through the tree it
splits into two pieces splits
splits and so on
if we root the tree then at that
location
we obtain the following rooted binary
tree
our goal then is to design a heuristic
that models a
molecular clock that assigns each leaf
an age
the age of each leaf node is zero
and then we need to assign ages to the
internal nodes the age of an internal
node
is going to represent how long ago the
speciation event
represented at that internal node
occurred
so for this monkey phylogeny the ages
are in millions of years
once we assign ages to the nodes of a
rooted binary tree
we get the weight of the edges of this
tree here shown in red
simply by taking the difference between
edge between the ages
so for example the age of this note is
the age of that note is 23 we get the
edge weight 10 for free just by
subtracting the two h's
furthermore if we assign ages to the
nodes of the tree
then it automatically implies that the
tree is what's called ultrametric
meaning that the length of every path
from the root to a leaf is the same
so here the age of the root is 33
million years
and the length of any path from the root
to a to a leaf node is 33.
so the heuristic that we're going to
introduce for constructing an
ultrametric
rooted binary tree is called upgma
which stands for unweighted pair group
method with arithmetic
mean upgma is going to construct an
evolutionary tree
by clustering the species from the
distance matrix into larger and larger
clusters
beginning with single element clusters
at each step it looks for the two
closest clusters
according to the average distance among
all pairs of elements taken from the two
clusters
now at this stage of the algorithm we're
dealing with single element clusters so
if we're looking for the closest
clusters
those that's just the smallest element
of the distance matrix which corresponds
to k and l
now i hope you're worried because we've
seen the perils of choosing
the minimum element of a distance matrix
as
neighbors but upgma is a heuristic and
it's not going to break like additive
phylogeny did
so once we found the two closest
clusters c1 and c2
we can merge them into a single cluster
c here we put
k and l into a cluster together because
they're the closest
we then can form a node for c and
connect that node
to both c1 and c2
we then set the age of this internal
node equal to half of this
average distance between c1 and c2 so we
saw that the distance from k to l was
two
so the age of this node is just one
we then recompute the average distance
between each pair of clusters
and we form an updated distance matrix
now we then just begin this process over
choosing a minimum element of our matrix
merging the two associated clusters
forming a new node for the merged
clusters which here is
i j and then assigning the age of this
node as half of the distance value from
the matrix
which was 3 here which gives us an age
of 1.5
after one more update of the distance
matrix
our only choice is to merge the
remaining two clusters
assigning an age of two and this yields
the final upgma tree
now here is the outline of upgma
provided on a single slide
please feel free to just pause the video
here if you need a little more time to
understand the algorithm
you should now be ready to implement
upgma and apply it to the coronavirus
data
of course sean will complain because we
never have really stated a computational
problem that upgma is trying to
provide an approximate solution for but
that's okay
the goal of upgma is not to fit a
distance matrix
but to provide a reliable method that
always can construct an ultrametric tree
regardless of what the input data is
so we know that the tree produced by
upgma
can't possibly fit this matrix because
the matrix is non-additive
you can see for example that the
distance from i to l
is 3 in the distance matrix but 4
according to the upgma tree
so in summary we've encountered two
methods for
constructing an evolutionary tree from a
distance matrix
additive phylogeny works if you give it
an additive matrix as input
but then on the other hand it fails
completely on non-additive matrices
then upgma in contrast
will produce a tree for any input that
you like
but the tree produced doesn't
necessarily fit an additive matrix in a
natural way
so can we possibly hope for an algorithm
one single algorithm that's going to
combine the better features of both of
these algorithms
in that it always produces the tree that
fits an additive matrix
but it also offers a good heuristic for
non-additive matrices